y aquí está la reacción general para la
migración del benceno empezamos con
nuestro benceno y añadimos ácido nítrico
y ácido sulfúrico concentrado así se da
la sustitución de un protón del benceno
por un grupo nitro veamos el mecanismo
para la ni tracción del benceno aquí
tenemos la estructura de louis para el
ácido nítrico y por acá tenemos la
estructura para el ácido sulfúrico que
es más fuerte que el ácido nítrico así
que el primer paso es que el ácido
sulfúrico actuará como un ácido de
brondsted lowry y donará este protón
entonces el ácido nítrico actuará como
una base es decir que un par de
electrones tomará el protón dejando
estos electrones con el oxígeno
dibujemos lo que resulta de esta
reacción ácido base aquí tenemos al
nitrógeno con una carga formal positiva
y está unido a este oxígeno también está
unido a este oxígeno que conserva su
carga parcial negativa y por acá tenemos
el otro oxígeno que ahora está unido a
dos hidrógenos
solo tiene un par de electrones libres
lo que le da una carga formal positiva
este par de electrones formaron un
enlace con este protón
por eso el oxígeno tiene una carga
formal positiva observen que se formará
agua como nuestro grupo saliente así que
estos electrones se moverán hacia acá
empujando a estos electrones hacia el
oxígeno dibujemos el resultado de eso
ahora nos ha quedado agua h2o y estos
electrones en rosa corresponden a estos
electrones así que el agua es nuestro
grupo saliente y nos queda el guión
nitro nio
se ve así y estos electrones son los que
formaron este enlace 'http y ahora el
nitrógeno tiene una carga formal
positiva y como tiene una hibridación
esp es lineal al tener esta carga
positiva será nuestro electro filo en el
mecanismo
este es nuestro electro filo y por acá
también hemos creado la base con jugada
del ácido sulfúrico hs o 4 menos
ahora veamos qué sucede una vez que ya
formamos a nuestro electro filo el
electro filo se adicionará al benceno
así que tendremos una reacción núcleo
filo electro filo dibujemos el anillo
aromático por aquí tenemos un hidrógeno
y ahora tenemos a nuestro ion nitro nio
la razón para que usemos un catalizador
es para producir a nuestro electro filo
cargado positivamente y ahora estos
electrones del benceno actuarán como un
núcleo filo y atacarán al electro filo
así que estos electrones atacan al
nitrógeno cargado positivamente y estos
electrones son empujados hacia el
oxígeno dibujemos el resultado de este
ataque el núcleo físico aquí tenemos
nuestro anillo
y aquí está el hidrógeno una vez más
mostraré la adición del electro filo en
este carbono así que tenemos al
nitrógeno unido con un doble enlace al
oxígeno de arriba y también está unido a
otro oxígeno con tres pares de
electrones libres lo que le da al
oxígeno una carga formal negativa y
claro el nitrógeno tiene una carga
formal positiva muy bien sigamos a los
electrones estos electrones que formaron
este enlace con nuestro grupo nitro y
como ya lo hemos visto muchas veces le
quitamos un enlace a este carbono así
que ahora tiene una carga formal
positiva dibujemos las estructuras de
resonancia
una de las estructuras podemos decir que
estos electrones se mueven hacia acá
entonces nos queda aquí tenemos al
hidrógeno y también el grupo nitro que
lo podemos escribir simplemente como no2
aún tenemos estos electrones pi y ahora
tenemos a los electrones bi que se
movieron hacia acá déjenme resaltar a
los electrones estos electrones vi en
azul ahora son estos electrones y como
le quitamos un enlace a este carbono
ahora aquí tenemos la carga formal
positiva aún podemos dibujar otra
estructura de resonancia ahora estos
electrones se mueven hacia acá lo que
claro le quita un enlace a este carbono
entonces
tenemos este enlace por aquí y por acá
tenemos la carga formal positiva así que
tenemos tres estructuras de resonancia
pero recuerden que el complejo sigma es
un híbrido de estas tres ya estamos
listos para el último paso la des protón
acción de nuestro complejo sigma
entonces si regresamos un poco que creen
que podría funcionar como una base claro
la molécula de agua así que un par de
electrones libres en la molécula de agua
tomará el protón dejando a los
electrones que se moverán hacia acá para
reformar el anillo aromático dibujemos
lo que nos quedaría se reforma el anillo
aromático y por la de explotación del
complejo sigma nos queda un producto con
la sustitución del grupo nitro
nuevamente resaltemos a los electrones
estos electrones en morado se movieron
hacia acá restaurando el anillo
aromático hemos formado nuestro producto
añadimos un grupo nitro y este es el
mecanismo para la ni tracción y ahora
que ya formamos un anillo con un grupo
nitro en él podemos hacer uso de la
síntesis para transformar el grupo nitro
en una lámina
veamos rápidamente una reacción muy útil
sobre esto podemos transformar el grupo
nitro en una mina de diferentes formas
una de las clásicas es reduciendo el
grupo nitro así que el primer paso es
usar hierro o estaño y una fuente de
protones como por ejemplo h
como esto es un ambiente ácido en el
segundo paso necesitamos neutralizarlo
con algo como hidróxido de sodio estos
pasos reducirán al grupo nitro en una
amina dibujemos el producto
ahora en lugar de tener no2 en el anillo
tenemos n h 2
esta es la molécula de anilina hay otras
formas de reducir el grupo nitro en una
mina pero es la forma clásica de hacerlo
esto puede serles muy útil para los
problemas de síntesis que estudiaremos
más adelante